the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
feel free to populate the front row I'm
not that scary wait ok so today we're
going to look at more greedy algorithms
so I think you went over Chris called
algorithm and how you do the sorting and
sorry in the conjecture so going back to
make change from last recitation so this
is like sort of a variant on that so
instead of discrete coins we now have
continuous coins in the sense of so like
the analogy here is let's say you have n
metals and each of the metals has some
value given by CI dollars per kilogram
or whatever units you prefer and you
want to achieve some value T you want to
give someone T dollars worth of metal
and you want to do this while minimizing
okay so I should mention this ki is the
weight of every metal that you will give
this gift give to the person so you're
taking ki of metal I and you are going
to and you have to ensure so basically
have to ensure that sum summation ki CI
over all I is equal to T and in doing so
you want to minimize the summation over
all ki so make sense so you have a bunch
of metal some of them are more expensive
than others and you want to measure them
out and give someone a certain fixed
value so anyone have any ideas how to do
this should be
should should be the first thing that
comes to mind so you have much of metals
some of them with certain costs and
you're trying to create a value T and so
which metal would you want to pick so
okay it should seem intuitive that you
want to pay if you want to minimize the
weight of the metal you would want to
pick the had the most expensive one per
wait wait so let's start by sort by CI
and we want to sort it in decreasing
order does that make sense so if you
have the most expensive metal you want
to use them as much of that as you can
so that your weight is minimized so once
you sort by CI so let's say you have
your costs right now hourly C let's call
this some C 1 C 2 up to CN and these are
in sorted order so it's increasing this
way so now you use so you now take your
value T and you look at T by C 1 and
that that is the amount of weight you
would need to generate C so you look at
look at how much how much you have here
so the amount of metal also constraint I
forgot to mention you are given a
limited amount of every metal ok back
that's that's okay that it's not that
reveal all right so you have let's
mention that so you have use notes on
I'm out does that make more sense so so
you look at T over CI and if T / CI is
less is greater than W Phi then you just
use the amount of amount you need to
construct WI and you're done
otherwise you use all of C one C I so if
it is if it's less than W I in that case
you sorry other way around if it's
greater than WI you use all you use all
of it and then you move on to the next
one and next one and so on so that seems
like pretty intuitive
let's actually do a formal proof of that
so how you go up proving this is that so
let's say so it's like all the current
base method so that's basically what you
have is let's say you're not using the
most expensive metal you have at this
point so let's say your most expensive
metal has cost CI but instead you decide
to use CJ so let's say you decide to use
some KJ amount of CJ so the so the value
you're getting from this is CJ KJ and
instead if you use CI how much how much
metal would you need to get the same
value you would need CJ KJ / CI is the
neck sense so this is this is the value
would obtain by using KJ pull up
kilograms of this metal so if you
instead use this one you get this value
and since you so this was this was the
most expensive one then CI is greater
greater than CJ this value so this value
is less than KJ so by using this metal
instead of that one you are decreasing
the amount but the weight you would need
so your so your minimization goes down
since that's like a very simple greedy
algorithm it's and like the other guys
know exactly exactly what you'd expect
and the proof isn't very hard so let's
move on to a more interesting more
interesting one
let's so this is process scheduling so
let's say you have a computer and you're
running n processes and each of the
processes at the time t1 through TN the
N processes and you want to order them
in some way so first you'll do process
p1 then you'll do process p2 and so on
and so forth
then you define a completion time so
completion time is simply when this
process I end so when this process I end
you just you want to speak like the time
for p1 plus sign is P 2 up to P n so
basically you have all your processes so
let's say this is this is p1 this is p2
and so on and the completion time for a
certain process in the middle it's just
the sum of all the times before it let's
complete your tag and now what you want
to do is want to minimize the average
completion time which is summation over
all completion times over n so any idea
is what an algorithm for this would look
like essentially you want to minimize
the sum of like all these times all
these times you want to minimize the
average of these so what do you want to
do you want to shift the slower shift of
like the processes take more time do you
want to keep them at the end or do you
get to at the beginning
so if you have a like a bunch of small
processes what do you do them at the end
what do you do the beginning
so completion time is when do so let's
say this is process bi and completion
time for process P I is like this
distance like when does P I get
completed so its summation of all the
times so the time taken for P 1 P 2 o to
the M so you want to basically minimize
the average of these values so would you
put the smaller process we could you put
the shorter processes at the end or a
beginning which one which one would
decrease your average beginning makes
sense right okay so yeah that makes
sense so you basically want to like
scrunch these lines towards the
beginning so your average is smaller
note that this this this total this
total length is always the constant it's
like summation over all TI so anyway so
let's go about so okay this is a
strategy again sort by TI and this is
increasing order and that's it basically
so this is your garden sort of idea and
put the user processing that order so
let's try to prove this so the way you
prove this is a pretty generic method
which is often used to prove to you
algorithms so let's say that this is not
the optimal let's say someone comes up
to you and tells you okay I have I have
a better I have a better sequence I have
a sequence let's take off let's say have
a sequence of p1 to PN and that sequence
does better than a sorted order so
you're like okay so if this is not not
sorted then you have some elements in
the middle let's say you call them P I
is greater than P J where PJ with I is
less than J so there's some P I hear
there's some PJ here such that this is
greater than that so it's on its own
sorted order so like that you can always
find a pair like that so now I'm just
now I'm going to claim that if you swap
if you swap these two values if you swap
bi and PJ that'll actually decrease
whatever current completes average
completion time you have so you have so
initially you had something like this so
no force entre
so let's say you had something like yeah
this process so the P I actually this is
the big processor it's like this FBI and
this is PJ and now I'm saying that and
II have some stuff in the middle and my
claim is that no this is not this is not
optimal you do much better if you move
the PJ over here so you want to go from
this to this and big process so let's
see what what changes when you go from
there to there so first of all observe
that the completion times of everything
behind this is the same they all have
the same condition and nothing is
affected and you're only changing like
these two things like everything after
this is also the same as the same
completion time so the only things that
are changing or this one this one and
all the ones up to this one even this
one has the same completion time make
sense so how much is it changing by so
let's define let's say so let's define
this Delta is equal to T of VI minus TF
PJ so the difference between these two
processes so what is it so the original
completion time was a VI was this and
now the corresponding process down here
the completion time is decreased by
Delta so completion time first goes down
by minus Delta this is just a summation
of completion times this divided by N is
a constant so it lets you just want to
minimize this so first it goes so this
one goes on minus Delta let's look at
the next process the NEX process
something like this so again is that
these are not change you're only
swapping these two so this completion
time also goes down with minus Delta and
so on and so forth so you just get a
bunch of - Delta's which is equal to
however many classes you have but that's
not even important what is important is
that just by swapping you're going to
get at least one minus Delta and Delta
is positive because assumption D this
assumption was that TP is - d PJ is
positive so just by swapping you're
going to always decrease it
so the claim that that sequence was an
optimal solution is wrong we can always
do better by swapping two inversions so
like those that out of sorted order is
called an
so if you swap an inversion you always
get a better result okay does that proof
make sense okay all right so that's a
slightly more interesting rhythm so
let's move on to the third one we have
here the third one is even event overlap
so this is how it works so so you wake
up in the morning and you look at your
calendar and being an MIT student your
calendar looks pretty full so let's say
this is what it looks like so these are
your events let's use some colors like
it's little very possibly and let's say
you have another event over here you
have something here and you have here
okay
actually so so the problem here is that
you have these bunch of events planned
out now clearly they're overlapping so
you can't attend all of them so the idea
you is you make a bunch of clones of
yourself and so in this case so look at
the matching color so if you create
clone number one goes here and clone
number two goes to the red input number
three goes to blue so then well number
one does this slow number three does the
blue one go number two does red I guess
we should move the red back a little bit
forward a little bit just to make it
clear yeah there we go
so and now now you can so now you could
easily see that this is optimal so you
can you can you can do this with three
clones and no less so you make three
clones and then you can go after Spring
Break and your schedule is fine so now
how would you approach this problem so
what is a greedy strategy to given a
number of intervals how do you find the
minimum number of bones you need to
cover your day any ideas what is a nice
thing you could do
so you want you want to do every you
want to do every event but you like so
this clone can't so a clone number one
does this event then you can't do this
event or this event you want to do all
the events you want to minimize the
number of clones so it's like interval
scheduling but you want to do all you
want to do all the intervals and but you
can but you're allowed to use multiple
people to do all the no so yes by n time
okay
what do you do after you sort band time
in
so you're close so you do begin by
sorting but so it's you can actually do
it by starting by in time it's easier to
visualize you sort by start time so
waiting from that anyone go to top and
yeah so yeah essentially every tie every
time you can't add it to one of your
current curves you create a new one
you could also do band time consume a
trick alright so you if you sort by n
time then you start with the smallest
loudest n time and go backwards exactly
the same thing so let's write down so so
start by start time and so actually
let's let's work out this example in
this case you would go okay actually so
if once you sort so first you have one
then you have two three four five six
that's sorted by start time and then we
have so you first you go for this one
then you go for two and two can
intersects with two hundred sex with one
so you put two into it so this is this
is clone number one and then you have to
create a new clone 42 so you create a
new clone and let me go so then you go
two three three clashes with both one
and two so you have to create a new
clone again so in that case you go forth
and create three then you go to four now
for you see is not it's passed for two
and three but it but it's going it a
good big one so you just put four over
here and if you continue like this you
essentially get this and this make sense
so that's how you schedule it so
little girl make sense let's try to
prove its correctness so let's say let's
look at the instance where you're
inserting them and Emmett clone so let's
up yeah let's go
so Emmett flown so when the electron is
created you already have some already
have some values in here so you have 1 2
all the way up to n minus 1 so now you
bring in your interval and you see that
it collides with all these values so
let's just draw the final interval for
all these guys so let's say the final
interval for this guy was out here let's
say the final interview this right
interval for this guy was out here and
so on blah blah blah and so when you
create the Emmett clone you look at the
start time so what happens is that the
start time start time is somewhere let's
say here and now you know that because
of this so you're only adding a new
clone when you don't have an available
slot so that means that there is some
interval here which intersects with this
guy okay so how do you prove so how do
you show that there's one interval so I
consider any level let's say there is no
interval intersects with it so that
means that there is either so there is a
so if there if there were gap here so
there were a gap here so let's say at
like this location this interval wasn't
here let's say you if you extrapolate
this line output so this is this is your
current starting value and let's say you
look at this line and in this segment
you can you can't have something which
starts after this because this is the
current highest sorting starting time so
there's no intervals which starts after
this so the only intervals that can
exist
I have already ended here and if they've
already ended here that means you can
have added it here so make sense yeah so
basically then you can show that ok so
and every every existing if you're
adding a new clone that means that every
existing level you have something which
intersects so what that means is that
you have
you have a single point of time where
there M minus one plus one intervals
that means that you absolutely need M
intervals regardless of what your
strategy is so adding the emeth clone is
necessary so if we go on continuous the
argument like let's say your total
number of clones with M so you can just
do this argument for M there you will
show that oh if I followed all these
rules correctly I can show that the
start time for M intersects with M minus
1 other intervals so there is no way I
can create a proper scheduling with less
than M clones did their argument make
sense or check over it again so that's
sort n baby but that should be okay okay
so uh well that's the three problems so
I guess you could go back to this one
and sort of give the motivation for this
so this could for example be used in
this could be used in scheduling
processes for strawberries for instance
so let's say your server gets requests
to run n processes and they have times
like that so this is like shortest time
first so you take all the short like the
smallest jobs and you execute them in
the beginning and you wait for other
jobs and this can also be done online so
you're gonna have an online version of
this so if you take this algorithm and
do it online so let's say your server is
running jobs and you get a new request
so you get a new request so you already
have some set of t1 to TN and let's say
you're running Jo at this cart at the
current moment TI is your smallest job
and you're running it and you're
currently at this point so and then you
can like in the middle of running it you
can get like a new request for jobs so
how would you modify this algorithm to
handle that so you still want to
maintain this like lowest average
completion time thing so how would you
handle this situation so let's say
you're in the middle of a job and you
get a bunch of new requests so your
current set is all these existing jobs
but some got some other things you get
in here so what what what would you
consider switching to a different job
here or would you keep doing this
let's say one of the ones let's say one
of the new jobs you get is really small
would use so what you would do in that
case is that instead of continuing with
this you would switch to the smokerin
smallest job so you you would look at
the remaining time so that's important
so you can forget about the amount of
time you've already spent on this you
know the remaining time is and that is
all that's relevant so if you just so
you can just like consider this problem
of different framing this exact same
process I think that it's the exact same
question you just look at remaining time
instead of like total time so if you're
in the middle of a job and if new one
comes in which is smaller you switch to
that complete that and go and then then
look at the remaining times for
everything so at some point of time you
might have like a lot of half completed
jobs just like lying around and for all
of them you will update their TI values
two remaining time rather than start
time and that gives you a nice way to
like decide which processes to do in
online and that gives you so this is
assuming that all of your all of your
tasks have equal weights so like all of
them have equal reward so obviously
that's not always the case you might
wonder might be like pushing back a very
long job forever because smaller things
keep coming in and that might get
important but if if everything is
equally weighted then this is the
optimal thing to do and it's a very
simple strategy it works hey so those
are the three problems on a discuss do
you guys have any other questions or
comments or anything good okay we push
pretty early so I guess I have a have a
great Spring Break